today's Monday minute is get inspired
every day you have to wake up and go to
work at your business you pound on your
craft and it's hard it takes you longer
any think it's going to take and you
have to go to work even if you see no
momentum happening around you and it's
soul-crushing you might be working less
than minimum wage at your business right
now and you think I'm worth more than
this how do you keep going you got to
get inspired for me what helps is I
surround myself with people who build me
up I read your youtube comments below
that are always positive empowering I
pick up books like The King years I talk
about Martin Luther King and his
struggle i watch youtube videos almost
every morning of people who who I look
up to who have great messages and
stories to share I get inspired every
day because you need that for your
business you have to believe in yourself
continuously and it seems like every day
you have to start from scratch so create
a schedule where you get inspired it's
important making an important part of
your daily life and it will get you
through all the hard times believe you
like this video give it a thumbs up
comment below subscribe thanks guys
we'll see you soon